David Addams résident de longue date de
forte Myers des tempêtes et même
l'ouragan Irma il les a tous vécus
mais il n'a jamais subi un ouragan tel
que Yann
de tempête c'est ce qu'on a eu dit-il il
avait ignoré l'ordre d'évacuation et
préférer rester dans sa maison avec sa
femme Angélique Yann a frappé durement
le sud-ouest de la Floride seulement sur
son passage la destruction et la
désolation
c'était incessant à souffler sans arrêt
au-dessus de nos têtes racontent ce
résident de Punta Gorda le métal frappé
contre le bâtiment il faisait sombre
mais pas moyen de savoir ce qui se
passait dehors les météorologues
prédisaient le pire et c'est ce qui est
arrivé
pour reprendre de plus belle
cela pourrait d'être l'ouragan le plus
meurtrier de l'histoire de la Floride
confirme Joe Biden même si lui est
impossible de dresser le bilan des
pertes humaines la Floride a déclaré
l'état de catastrophe majeur dans
l'ensemble de ces compter
l'administration fédérale a accepté
d'assumer tous les coups du sauvetage
d'une nettoyage
le niveau de l'eau continue de monter
aujourd'hui même après la tempête c'est
un événement qui survient au 500 ans
dans les zones sinistrées les secours
s'organisent en bien que mal par voie
terrestre quand les routes sont
praticables abordent embarcation dans
les zones inondées
à coup de hache s'il le faut pour sortir
des citoyens bloqués dans leur véhicule
la direction des températures
l'importance de la convection la force
de rotation de la tempête ce concours de
circonstances favorisant le
développement assez rapide l'énergie que
nous regardent se puisse dans l'eau
chaude donc si on réchauffe le climat si
on réchauffe la surface terrestre
notamment les océans on va donner plus
d'énergie aux tempêtes qui vont se
produire même sur la côte Est de la
Floride Yann s'est fait sentir on a eu
environ 16 pouces de pluie en 12 heures
c'est des mini tornades et des tornades
qui peuvent être quand même
dévastatrices
attentats les dégâts sont minimes est
partie les rayons de soleil commencent
là justement à sortir en fin de journée
donc nous on peut tourner la page
Yann se dirige vers la Caroline du Sud
laissant derrière lui un état ravagé qui
aura besoin de beaucoup de temps et de
moyens pour se reconstruire
ici Yasmine Raya Radio-Canada Montréal